welcome everyone um we're really excited
to have uh our fourth and final Deans
invited speaker uh for this semester uh
we'll have more to come we'll announce
those soon um and thanks again to SII
City for letting us uh host these here
it's been it's been a great great series
for us um this is a one I'm really
looking forward to uh Royal Hansen uh is
the VP for security at Google uh he was
class of
97 um same class as my sister actually
uh and also in Sab you may know her
Susie Brock you don't know if that rings
the bell that we've never put that
together we'll have to talk about that
that's my whole sister yeah in any case
um so we just made that connection which
is interesting uh he was a computer
science major learned everything he
knows from uh Mike fiser here in the
front row about security so um and uh
you can blame him for Google foibles and
that's
said uh so so prior to that he worked
for American Express as a VP for
information and Technology security okay
and at Morgan Stanley um so we're really
excited to hear from him about how he's
thinking about Security in the sort of
New Era of of AI systems and how they're
being deployed the way that these kind
of call on questions of privacy and
security as we input our information so
that we can get answers to the questions
we'd like to know the answers to um lots
of questions needing to be asked
answered and explored uh with this you
know massive scale compute that's going
on at Google so we're we're kind of
relieved to know that a friend a child
of Yale University is at the helm of
this uh this bold new effort at Google
and we're really excited to hear from
him he's going to give about you know 25
30 minutes of remarks and then we'll
open it up for questions so you have
plenty of time to to ask and we'll
address your questions after that great
all right welcome Ro and it was great we
saw each other not even a week ago is it
or maybe it's a little over a week it's
something like that um in California I I
was super impressed with the collection
of Deans how many Deans did you have
there all of them it really was all of
them
yeah and I mean I it's apart from that
just being impressive it is one of the
reasons I've wanted to get closer to the
university again and really as the
computer science department has sort of
expanded I mean that's probably an
understatement um you know when I
graduated I bet you know if we asked you
had to guess there were eight of us in
the major so it's sort of it's like a
different ER I mean it might as well
been in the 19th century uh not the 20th
but um to see though the full University
come together around some of these
topics I don't you know as a one someone
who wants to participate in these
discussions and help Society work out a
lot of these questions I think Yale has
an incredibly important role to play and
I would like to you know help in that
and be a part of it so I really do feel
like uh the meetings we've had over the
last year and even today the students
professors not just in the computer
science department I'm I'm super excited
for so as we well I have maybe 15 slides
sort of relatively quick and just
hopefully set the table but as de Brock
said I I do privacy Safety and Security
um anything bad that can happen at
Google and so we could talk about any of
that as you as you ask questions the
slides are more about AI just because I
think it's something that's uh it's more
topical and and and sort of front of
mine for me at the moment but happy to
go in a variety of
directions um let's see with
that the rendering across the Google uh
um in uh slides instead of PowerPoint
probably gets that AI in the wrong place
the the first point I'd like to make and
that and as we go through the
slides I think we sometimes forget that
in the security of AI so this means
think about like software security data
protection
um
cryptography that's a whole body of work
and I'll talk about that in the second
half but I've been really impressed and
excited about the uses of of these large
language models in AI more generally in
the service of Safety and Security so
I'm just going to remind us a little bit
about that in the beginning so that in
our enthusiasms to kind of restrict and
and and regulate you know you see lots
of you saw the White House this week and
lots of efforts and it's all good
efforts to come to grips with it but we
are doing some incredible things as a
society you think of the alpha fold that
just the most recent publication this
week the protein Pathways like we're
going places we've never been and I I
suspect really really just at the
beginning and those are in the service
of health safety even if not you know
and and I'll talk about a few examples
of cyber security but to me there are
two topics how do we use this stuff to
make people safer and how do we secure
it make it safe itself so I'll cover
both of
those um you know wildfires just a few
real world examples and then we'll get
into the more technical side that in
California in particular obviously in C
uh Canada this year I was in Greece um
uh last month for a democracy forum and
it tells you kind of the I joined Google
because I felt like it was a moment
where people would all of a sudden want
to talk not just about the technical
work but the implications of it so in
Athens we were talking about the de the
role of democracy and Technology we went
with the government there and they're
busy in the face of both floods and
fires thinking about how they deploy
into areas where there's very little
electricity little power and even
internet connectivity how do you get
very lightweight sensors so they can
detect early fires and flood conditions
to get ahead of these things but it's
interesting that like that that happened
in California happening in Greece
happening all over the world for climate
related activity I think enormous
opportunities to use AI there the next
one you know obviously we talk about uh
whmo or Cruise or these different
examples of self-driving cars but the
the um the safety benefits of using
large models in transportation are
incredible now I my brother-in-law
always tells this story he was one
remember of the American Medical uh
Association when they convinced the
airlines to let two years years and
under uh children fly on laps because
they didn't want to do that because they
were going to kill so many children in
accidents in the flights and they made
the mathematical argument that you would
save children's lives because they
wouldn't fly they would drive those 200
300 400 mile trips and if you just did
the Actuarial analysis you would kill
more children under two by forcing them
to have a seat belt on a flight than by
letting them sit on their parents lap
and just given it an example of where
it's that kind of analysis I think we're
all going to have to do as we think
about the application of these
Technologies in different Arenas it
doesn't mean that it will always be the
right answer but I think you could AR
you can make a pretty strong argument
that the safety benefits if we look at
it through with clear eyes will be
greater in taking some risk with the
technology than in than in being
conservative again that's going to vary
but I I think it's a really good example
um I talked about Alpha fold and I'm
most excited about the uh the
developments in health and you know
computational biology um uh and and the
use of AI I actually think it's an area
where Yale I'm sort of really excited to
see where you all go given the strength
of the molecular biology program here
and the combination with the sort of
growth in the technology side I
mentioned deep mind when you go to the
Deep Mind uh or the alpha fold paper
when you go to the Deep Mind office in
London they don't put up any of their
technical papers on the wall like sort
of in sort in the lobby they put up only
their science papers
nature um uh science Health they are in
this to solve human problems not just
you know this all tools to them to get
these things done and I i' super impr
impressed with that group if people have
ever heard Demis hassabis talk who's the
CEO it's just incredible and has become
a friend as all of this has come
together but I think I'm really inspired
by the work they do in health and I
actually think it's probably the area we
will be most surprised at the
developments using AI just one slight
sidebar on that is that my senior
thesis uh we couldn't get David glarner
to come to this I guess but
um I he daveid was my uh senior thesis
adviser and I I've tried to look back in
you know my email records are not great
from uh the yale.edu era and um I need
the Google search of the that but he had
a um um multi-dimensional cluster
analysis really I think it's called
Diana maybe or something like that but
that very early on they had used to do
mamogram kind of detecting anomalies in
in
mammograms this is you know this is '90s
and now we're you know the really seeing
the sort of progression in that work but
um you you know way back when that's
what was going on here using neural
networks in their mer basic levels
that's what I started doing uh at at
Yale years ago super excited about
that um I mentioned cyber security so
again before we even get into securing
AI it's worth noting that so this the
example I have on there is the Play
Store so they're every day we scan 128
billion appto device pairs to make sure
they're still operating in a way that
you know we get the sort of uh safety
the No No harmful apps found and so you
get that in the Android ecosystem you
can't look at 128
billion apps or app instances without
using some sort of large modeling
capabilities and this goes back further
than the large language model models but
we're using you know machines humans are
not looking at that stuff this is all
purely done through the training of
classifiers and looking for anomalies in
behavior of on device
apps real world making people safer you
know across the globe uh uh at the
billions of people scale gmail which
people would you know I think you
probably are more than familiar with but
the I we could take a poll on whether
people are happy or sad with the spam
filters at the moment but but um you
know it's a hard problem because the in
cyber security we have the opposite
problem of some of these other areas
where you're aiming for a perfect
score every time you get to a perfect
score and you block all the fishing
attacks again using these classifiers
the adversary is sentient and active
they are looking at it and and changing
their approach so there's no such thing
as ever getting to 100% you get to 100%
they're immediately going to change the
their approach often times even
weaponizing your defenses against you so
it's in some ways what makes the field
really really fun because it's got it
never ends it's other thing that makes
it really difficult because you know I
get beaten up semi-regularly because we
let too much spam in in trying to tune
this so it really is like keeping a ship
afloat to keep it at the right
tolerance for for those classifiers
because we're you know we're looking at
literally hundreds of billions of
messages over over the course of a week
the last one which I don't think most
people probably know about in by Design
and probably the best
example something called safe browsing
so years ago Google realized we would
learn pretty quickly when a fishing site
had been stood up to be the basis of a
email and link to get someone to enter a
password or download some sort of
malware you know then Watering Hole
attacks start to occur where you're just
browsing you're searching set up a site
to look like a site you're used to and
it drops malware on your local device we
would pick these things up just for the
scope of what we saw on the internet and
start to build a list and block those
things from ever those sites from ever
being rendering or in the case where we
weren't sure but it looked like it might
be a problem we would give a warning we
put that behind Chrome but that's now
behind Safari it's behind
Firefox um you know in in some forms
it's even behind the um you know other
browsers and it's on four billion
devices you we're sort of talking on the
order of magnitude of the number of
people on the planet that have access to
the internet every time they go to a
site whether they know it or not it's
being checked against these known lists
you know and we start to offer things
that allow the time between detection
and and usage in the uh in the browser
to even go down to under 30 minutes so
all of that using sort of what you'd
call Old School uh uh machine learning
this is not necessarily the large
language models but this is what we've
been doing for many years to solve these
kinds of problems at
scale
um so that's using AI to keep people
safe broadly physically as well as in
the cyber security world the next sets
of slides are about how do you make this
new fangled AI infrastructure whether
it's gpus and tpus whether it's
foundational models or Frontier models
that then are distilled and deployed
into all these other form factors chat
Bots and and otherwise how do you make
that secure by default uh one of the
things I love about Google is we early
on decided we didn't want to put too
many bells and whistles on the front
like that safe browsing the bet you're
better off as a user if you never have
to worry about the security if you if we
force you to deploy another piece of
software and configure it we're likely
to fail because people are not going to
do it they're not going to do it well so
how do we make this AI infrastructure
secure by
default um and just to give you a taste
for the kind of the problems that we're
up against I talked about uh the
biological uh Sciences just to give we
we were at Stanford I guess I can say
that I don't know what the rivalries are
these days on these but um you know but
in the spirit of an academic activity um
with the computer science department and
the biology
department and you know you see these
four base pair Primitives for DNA just
to give it to a hook to talk about this
increasingly the 3D printing
world through model organisms if you
want to think about that whether yeast
or others you can give a computer the
instructions the DNA to RNA
and then protein pathway just like Alpha
fold instructions to create life in in
various forms in in
fact
um the story they told was these are
sort of the this is Switzerland Italy
France in the case of um coid so if you
think back to sort of the very earliest
months of of 20 this is that that says
March right here and you see that in
Italy it was first but it um Co 19 was
transmitted from China over the internet
in its DNA instructions to the who in
Switzerland and then
printed and existed in Switzerland in
that area 10 over 10 days
before it arrived via human
transmission so when I talk about doing
security I don't mean it's just for
email or websites we're we're headed to
a world world where the structures of
life and Society are digitized and then
the whole supply chain needs to be safe
because the mistakes here are very
different than in one where your email I
I miss a a a Spam uh message so it kind
of gives you a sense of where we're
headed and AI being a really big part of
that um one other uh idea that we've
talked a little bit about I think again
is a good one for the context of Yale
is and I'll just start with the big
picture question and then explain it
what is a country on the
internet you so much of the discussions
that I get involved in are well does the
data resident in the
country can the government have access
to this data who which um
jurisdiction has uh sort of sovereignty
over this
question and um it doesn't really map to
the technical world you all know this
very well we spent the last 50 years
trying to distribute data and
computational power everywhere it needs
to be we didn't it's not really grounded
in the geography of a
map the the example that I sometimes
talk about there's a professor at
Claremont who wrote his dissertation on
um the Inception or the sort of
development of cargraphic Technology
in the 15th and 16th century and the
establishment of the nation state
there's you know historically we thought
of France and England and these sort of
European nation states coming into form
because of Hobbs and lock and these kind
of sort of theory of of how to run a
state he makes the case that actually
you couldn't have
France before you could build a very
specific map and replicate it and
distribute it so that you could even
talk about the thing France
just it's an interesting question this
sort of intersection between the
material conditions or the technology
developments and the political and
societal structures that go with
it my question I think one we should
work on as a community is what is the
nation state I get in these weird
discussions with people about the
location of our data center and people
have religious discussions about this I
get the spirit of it but that's just not
the way the internet and applications
and software work you want these things
to have
interconnectivity people are not going
to go to the data center with a forklift
and get the rack and take it away and
then use forensic uh software to get the
data there are much more normal ways to
get at that data if you wanted to do it
so I think this discussion of what is a
country in an era of the internet is
super interesting and related to then
how we solve question questions of
security privacy safety because you know
you're going to have legal and
Regulatory other activity on top of that
the the other example related to that
just again some images that'll recall it
is I was in Paris don't tell aen this
this my friend uh in the political
science department um
uh that talking about a new cyber
security related law uh and uh one of
the ministers said to me you know we are
Latin in our sort of History like the
Latin Roman tradition of Law and we're
addicted to writing laws like we really
like it um which is great and you know
to get how people sort of go after their
governance and things but I said what
will happen when the laws we continue to
write are now expressed or written or
mapped to
Cobalt and we're 50 years down the road
and someone needs to change that law
you're not going to be able to pull it
off the
shelf and edit it and publish it back
and have people obey it somebody's going
to have to know how to change the cobal
I just use that as sort of an Antiquated
version people even know what cobal is
here anymore okay good maybe we should
use something another example for the
depending on the crowd Fortran I don't
know what the uh my prologue interpreter
written in lisp what was the that was my
favorite project my favorite uh um
problem set with I can't remember who
had us do that um but but really you in
technology we in technology are will be
coding the laws of today and
tomorrow and then changing them will be
a uh availability risk people things
will break let alone will they will the
spirit of the law actually meet the
spirit of the the the regulation so
again in all these areas of AI or I mean
AI is going to make this even more
complicated but it just it happens today
in the context of of
software and just to maybe bring that a
little bit closer to home I was in I
spent a lot of time in Poland over the
last 18 months after the invasion uh of
Ukraine and you know we've gotten to
know the cyber security community in
Eastern and Central Europe really well
because it's the truth is that the
attacks on Ukrainian infrastru structure
go back to
2014 uh and the wiper and many of the
kind of uh destructive malware you've
seen are a result of attacks on Ukraine
from Russian threat actors back in 2016
and Beyond um the latest uh developments
though that when I was last in Poland
with the Cyber command group there you
now have weapons we saw what was I think
the uh Dutch just announced something
about
a aircraft that's being you that're
being delivered but they pointed out to
us that the supply chain for ships
trucks warehouses for all these weapons
or supplies that are ultimately flowing
through Poland and into Ukraine are the
that's the
underbelly of the cyber security issue
because Russian threat actors track that
if they can figure out which device
which weapon which Supply is going where
when
strategic Advantage not just in the
battlefield but in sort of the the the
broader context of war
and that's got nothing to do with the
military or the government these are
like Mom and popop warehouses and
trucking companies who who know nothing
about Google or Morgan Stanley's level
of cyber security these people are as
vulnerable as anyone on the planet to
these attacks I say all of those things
then to to say we are working on this
framework called the secure AI framework
and just the spirit of it is to not
throw out in this new rush to AI all of
the improvements and
foundational uh security work that we've
built up over the last couple decades
think of Supply chains think of um kind
of the the full stack of a piece of
software I'm not going to drain it here
because it's more of a a framework but
the idea is that the way we handle data
um the way we write you know the logic
the business logic of a piece of
software the way the input is validated
think in the context of AI historically
for a website you would validate the
entry that a user uh put in before you
passed it along the database people have
heard of things like SQL injection or
sort where the the code is passed the
database and if not checked can extract
more data than you would think sort of
simple approach to it but in the world
of a of a large language model there is
no dis there's no
intermediation of the language because
the language is the code the the model
interacts with the English that the user
types in so your ability to constrain
that or to check it is dramatically
changed from where you've got JavaScript
or something on the server side so all
of a sudden we got a whole new class of
ways of trying to solve this in input
validation or data lineage think of the
other thing that how do we know which
data is being used in training how do we
know where the data goes that's entered
into the models that's what this is
designed to do is to take the best of
the last 20 years and make sure in the
flurry of activity we don't forget all
these foundational things things we
learned in uh in the in the cryptography
courses we don't throw those out just
because you know you do have this risk
every time there's a massive uh
Innovative moment that people uh build
it from scratch very quickly to get to
Market and they forget about all the the
the work we've done over the years to on
security so I I hope that's at least a
table setting and I I think the the key
for me is
that and the reason I came to Google was
I I could never solve the problems we're
talking about or participate at One bank
or one you know institution you had to
be part of this fabric of Technology
whether it was uh data centers and Cloud
whether it's mobile devices whether it's
email and uh video rendering I think
that we're at a unique moment where the
infrastructure for the 21st century is
being laid down if we mess it up now
it'll be like the
railroads of um of a of a previous era
and we you won't change those the gauge
of the Railways again so we'll live with
whatever uh infrastructure security we
build right now for
AI uh love to answer questions that'd be
great
thanks I'm sort of fascinated by the
framing you give Royal about the need
for a certain level of
scale and I think you know we we wrestle
with this in in universities as we do
strategic planning and think about how
we can you know we're not going to be in
the business of competing on scale with
Google but we do want to feel like we're
part of a conversation that involves
leadership where the scale exists um
what do you see the right kind of way
for universities to engag with these
questions which clearly are affecting
and asking questions that leaders in
Academia should be thinking about yeah I
mean the the good news is I think on on
work like the data centers
networks AI kind of at the foundational
levels there's actually really rich
exchange between Academia and these tech
companies um I think the the the problem
or the the question really for the next
step is that's been siloed on our
side and somewhat siloed I think in the
academy and so finding
concrete and you you told me this I
think the first time we met which I
think is was it helped me frame some of
my thinking it's one thing to talk in
the abstract it's another thing to have
a joint project on a particular question
a legal a
regulatory question the the good news is
the Googles of the world are now much
more in the middle of those legal and
Regulatory questions whether we like it
or
not so now we're I think more open than
may you know I don't I don't think 10 15
years ago it would have been even
interesting or relevant to some of these
companies to be in those discussions I
think it is now how do we bring the
other departments around the university
to the table in concrete enough ways it
struck me we talked about this before
like as the Deans are all around that
room let's have to have one conversation
in that room but could it become 15
conversations about regulation Health
Care you know different areas so I I
would I think you can help us by
convening that cross-disciplinary work
in ways that we would never even know
how to yeah I I'm looking forward to
that so first of all and uh I think
second of all it is it is interesting
how we are already seeing um kind of
calls on computer science and on um the
technical side from engineering from the
other schools you know we need not just
to apply app algorithms to say medical
data or problems like this but to really
understand mechanistically how these
things are working how they're
processing information so I think I
think that's a that's a key point the
the other thing though that that
sometimes we hear internally to
engineering is well you know we we saw
neural networks and then there was a
long winter and then there was a little
sort of data science blip and then there
was another Long Winter and this is just
going to be another hype cycle and
there'll be another long AI winter do
you do you see that as that's a great
question because I you know I've seen
number of those along the way I you know
just personally and then and the more I
work with the Deep Mind folks and others
in in the kind of work we're talking
about whether it's for the malware
analysis or safety filtering on the
internet uh I people I really respect
that are not into this for
for the investment side because I think
that you know sort of add it's helpful
but not always the right
signal are are surprised at the what
this is able to do in ways that I think
make me feel like we
are there's still a lot to go here and I
and just my thinking on it you know just
for what it's worth to talk about is
that the big difference is going to be
can these large models or
next layer up from them become the
equivalent of the operating system
instead of you going you know all these
problems I talked about before you go
and solve one use case at a time and you
train data and you tune the data and
then you put it at a particular point in
the logic of the code to make a
decision I'm starting to see instances
where the user themselves in interacting
with that next layer
of you know model tune the model as they
use it and so you that will be far more
effective and and
efficient in writing software than
having a software developer in the
middle of that activity if we can do
that I think you that is that is a very
different world than one of a bunch of
Linux boxes strung together running some
middleware right right and I think
that's that's what that's what people
working on yeah that I mean I I think
that's one of the things we heard when
we were out west is that this this um
changes the way anyone can interact with
a computer whether it's someone who
wants to write a technical piece of code
or someone who just kind of wants to
take an idea and turn it into something
that can be deployed technically I mean
the interest I and I'm really enjoying
this I talk about my you know the the
the back to the neural network with
Professor learner was
that you
um you know so much of the work
historically went into training you or
into labeling data obviously the Deep
learning quickly allowed us to label
Auto label data and train these models
but what I didn't realize is this
reinforcement learning with human
feedback and different versions of that
you know if you can get a an expert to
react to the output of one of these
models you can immediately use that
feedback and it's the model gets
exponentially better not just a little
bit better M and it's so all of a sudden
the user becomes the most valuable piece
of the equation it's why I'm actually
not worried about the labor questions in
many ways I actually think people are
going to find this remarkably de
Democratic and democratizing because
they're going to be able to do things
they were never able to and they in fact
will add what they know that nobody else
knew and the model will get that much
better that quickly but that's not the
way we write software and that's what
that's the work that's got to be done
because you can't just say okay let's
use it like an operating system that
isn't like that's how it works
interesting we were talking a little bit
earlier about how uh as as products of
Yale you have a kind of a a latent
humanism that is kind of baked into your
brain regardless of what you end up
doing um what you know as we think about
strategically what makes the most sense
for us to be doubling down on here how
do you see your own experience at yels
and forming your work on the one hand
and two do you think we uh have kind of
a privileged position or you know
strategic advantage in terms of bringing
these broad strengths of the University
across the hum's Arts law policy Etc to
to this discussion I I definitely think
you do and I and that's something I
would like to be a part of and hope you
know we we I can help in in any small
way
but I think and and again going back to
what you said and this we need to spend
more time on on the on the concrete
activity between departments I think
we'll have lots of great discussion the
beauty of this place it could convene
and you can do things like this and many
others but to make it concrete and
progress the
discussion and then and rusa I think we
uh we met with this morning who's great
we s could couldn't stop um she's
fabulous she's great uh but but we
really sort of mind melded on this idea
of abstraction
layers so I spend a lot of my time at
Google trying to convince these
Engineers that it's you know in the
early days of Google if you would dealt
with an abstraction layer you were a
loser because you couldn't code like you
had to talk about these things like you
were like this and Jeff's probably the
patron saint of that stuff right like
these people were handson in ways that
was just not true but we've gotten to a
point where I would argue you can't you
can't embed all those laws in code you
can't right it that becomes a weakness
if you can't abstract and interact I
mean apis being the sort of web services
being some instances but I think we need
to take it even further in the
abstraction and that was the point so I
think the law school the health like can
we come up with a
vocabulary that is that matches the
abstraction layer that is concretely
mapped to to technology and to policy
law scientific you know
laws to me that's the work that has to
be done and so instead of just talking
about it can we pick these domains and
say we're going to that's why I like the
safe framework s like find a each of
these domains is going to need a
technical abstraction layer that they
can
reliably do their work on and still have
it map to the technical implementation
right now that happens through your
software developer somewhere or some
other
company I so there's almost like a
vocabul i me which I think the academy
is good at right like this is the whole
scientific your your sort of uh genus
and species that's what we're talking
about and I mean we've had a couple of
conversations with uh AI folks about
what this is revealing about the
structure and indeterminacy of language
itself you know almost from a
mathematical perspective not that we
haven't been studying language
mathematically for many years but the
the the mathematical questions become
part of how the algorithms work I mean
in terms of how you do search through
language and how you represent language
all these things you're talking about I
mean one one just quick example of that
that sort of I mean makes sense but
surprised me was that if you train a
model on just text sort of one
mode and you train even with on smaller
amount of the vi image and
text that second model is better at text
only mhm because to your point our ideas
and what we understand are not perfectly
abstracted to language and in fact it
learns something that we don't express
directly you you it's lossy right
language to ideas is loses
information I have I'm sorry I just have
one more question I have to ask and I'll
open it up that so on this point kind of
the way that that t that images can
improve the way language inter or
language models work do you see
projecting forward a future where in
some sense by say representing by
ingesting video and having this be part
of the the language which I know we're
already doing but that there's an
opportunity to explore how these models
actually learn like something like
physics like watching balls bounce and
things like this I mean is that is that
something you're thinking about at
Google yeah I you know this would be now
you're getting you know beyond my
primary experience but my what in my
world version of that the modality I
think we need to think about what a
modality is right just because you can
write it in English what I think to
think of that like a
ladder all of these things will ride on
the language and image then they need
the modality of the of the Arena you
know in my case logs like we're going to
train these large language models with
an additional modality of logs because
logs are yes they're text but they're
not language right right and I think for
each of those domains there will be a
refining
modality which maybe it's dimensionality
in maybe it's some
geometric modality that needs to be
introduced but the thing about it is
it's not don't think of those as
separate back to the operating system
language I think is a Fant fantastic
language and visual are fantastic
foundational models that mean you don't
have to you're not starting from scratch
in something like physics or biology you
can still use the the whatever is baked
in to the understanding of language so I
mean the fact that we're even able to
have a conversation as bizarre as this
one I think represents a turning point
in the evolution and history of these
these Technologies but I want to open it
up to the audience who took time out of
their day to come hear yes we have a
microphone actually which would be great
for the video so I got uh maybe a little
bit of a boring question you probably
get this a lot but you're you know
you're involved with security at Google
dealing with AI risk uh how big do you
think uh existential risk of AI really
is how should Google be taking steps to
sort of you know prevent that from
getting out of hand um how are you
thinking about that and then also you
know in computer science there's often
this dialectic between like making
something open source and making it
secure and that's why everyone like know
loved blockchain for the time that we we
had it right
is really seem to be very promising so
how do you ensure that when you're
securing everything and making AI secure
to prevent that existential risk you're
not also preventing small players in the
marketplace from actually being able to
do cool stuff with AI and kind of
drawing a moat around you know meta
Google and uh and Microsoft and open
AI
right disclaimer before I answer some of
these these questions
uh nothing going on in the world on that
front at the moment
um let's see um let's see the first one
was on sorry I lost as you got started
about antitrust I got thinking about
that sorry um existential risk yeah so
again not I've not spent my life like
some of the the folks in the I
research and I think we should respect
and do think about alignment in these
questions but from a practical
perspective in this
security the the thing that gives me
some comfort
and sort of there's a downside to it as
well is most of the world is not
automated very well I think about how
much of the world you still you know the
technology stops well short of full
Automation and that's gonna that means
that like even the best ml model in the
world knows how to kill everyone
whatever that is it's not going to be
able to do it because the things aren't
automate so we're going to have to like
we still got a lot of work in the world
to automate even the very B basic things
we we can you can all imagine things
that you could do much more automated
with your phone or thing so I think
we've got a long ways to go in not the
ml work just continuing to instrument
and
automate everything you know the the
world we live in you know if you lived
in a perfectly automated world where
everything you thought could be done you
know then you then I think you then you
begin to have those we've got a lot of
work I mean as someone who lives you
know 30 you know we got 180,000 thousand
people at Google and you know it's
remarkably slow how uh how much is still
not automated in Even in our world so I
think I mean I don't say that with pride
I just think it's a reality of where
we're at it's not just the model is not
on its own able to automate things that
are not automated someone's gonna have
to do that um and I think it's it's a
good you know that it's it's a good
example of where the practitioner
somebody said I'm like the map is not
the territory if that makes sense person
can know the map the model can know the
map perfectly that doesn't mean they can
manipulate the
territory um on the second question I
you know I don't know it's a good
question on where open source models
closed Source Frontier and foundational
models versus
distilled I again my only thing would
you say I think over time these
foundational models will be more like
operating systems and people will ride
on them whether whatever form of getting
there whether open source or not I think
the constraints in many ways are more
just the work it goes into building
those Frontier and foundational models
whe you know whether the open source not
but I'm not this is not I don't I don't
know enough
about the domain specifically to to be
I'm I'm just charged with securing it if
I if it goes
wrong any question over
here thank you I was just curious with
all of these new Frameworks coming out
from different companies and governments
um they have a lot of different pillars
uh learning from history uh I'm curious
what you think are the uh largest areas
that they're missing or that they're not
putting enough emphasis on or any
shortcomings that you see in these um
new pillars of safety and ethics yeah I
think the two hardest areas is not
because people aren't saying it but are
the the data questions and then the
interface the user input
um I don't think that people are missing
that I just think there's still work to
be done to to codify and commoditize the
controls so everybody can do that but
I'm not um maybe back to the question I
think maybe the people are over indexing
at times to the the the the the large
the other question the kind of larger
risks I'm pretty focused here on the
plumbing that like how does how do we
make this thing stable solid reliable
repeatable for
everybody uh and so maybe to the degree
that people are distracted by some of
the longer term risks from the shortterm
that's what I'm worried about thank
you other
questions
yeah so you said AI has been using very
like different fields including the
economics and also like the the
Technologies but how of the fields that
has relatively low tolerance of air for
example the health care and autonomous
vehicles what do you think how reliable
and how secur is in those fields it's a
great question um you know the the
Hallucination is one thing in a chatbot
it's a totally different thing in a in a
health care device is that the you know
the spirit of the the question I think
look a little like Quantum Computing the
same thing most of the work and it's
even back to this question question of
risks of input and and
output um I think we've got more work to
do to to make those safe in more and
more sensitive worlds but that's the
work that's going on just like in
Quantum Computing the real question is
can you make error correction
efficient um I think the same thing is
going to go on here how how far down can
we drive the error bars on those
hallucinations in different Arenas the
good news is
this is back to my point of like if you
ride on a foundational model and then
you keep distilling it it actually you
know chess is the simple example but Al
I think it's already proving that it can
do these things very very well if you
constrain it enough and the question is
can you relax the constraints and get
the Precision you need that's the front
line of the work right now for
sure yeah right here go
ahead thank you um so in terms of
Regulation and security with uh newly
developed AI
models and you um mentioned that you
think that the user experience is
integrated integrated within the
software um what's your approach with
regulating or your conceptual approach
with regulating it in terms of like
starting Broad and then specify it down
to case models when my experience um and
my use of an AI may be different than
someone else's do you start broad do you
start with more specific instances and
then connect those to like a broader
umbrella or is there a specific path
that you would think would be optimal
for taking it's a good you know it's a
good question in a couple of ways one my
first answer is and this is informed
from living in banks for a while I think
it's important not
to
um this of over M make cyber security or
AI overly precious and to remember that
that these things are done in the
service of a particular domain you know
Financial Services Transportation health
care and what we really want to regulate
is the outcomes in that
domain the problem is that you know this
and this happened in cyber security to
us like that everybody rushes to the new
fangled area and wants to regulate it as
a class unto itself I think the mature
state will become healthc care will use
AI in lots of interesting ways and there
will be regulation that is specific to
healthare I Think It's tricky to imagine
all the implications or KnockOn effects
of AI r large with enough Precision to
be a
helpful guard rail that doesn't mean
that I I think what's useful now is lots
of people at the table learning and
getting better but my hope would be that
they become industry specific and their
agnostic to AI what we care about is
outcomes and risks um because the things
going to change so quickly I don't think
I think we always get in trouble when we
overs specify regulatory action to
technology that changes faster and
faster every year the other one though
that I I think this is back to the the
university look there's a whole I mean
political theory is all about this stuff
like how do you regulate well it scares
it scares me that when the tech like I
don't want just the tech industry doing
this I want good thoughtful regulation I
don't want reactive regulation as a
weapon I want it as a collaboration for
healthy Innovation and outcomes so I
think the university you know instead of
this being Tech against somebody else
how do we together write good regulation
that promotes the level of innovation
and competition like I that's that's the
right thing you know you've seen lots of
the what was the video recently about
the Telecom industry like we're pretty
good at doing regulation bad in in many
it's whole concept of regulated capture
and all this stuff so how do we do it
better I don't know that we are the we
do not have the corner on on that
question can you speak just for a second
about how this intersects um issues of
intellectual property when you're
training on you know vast amounts of
data some of which may or may not be um
owned and then reproduced and you know
that's a regulatory question but it's
also just a it's a technological
question in terms of what the mashup is
that is spat out by the algorithm of PM
it's a great topic that will be more
than just Technical and I think that's
the like so on the technical side lots
of work going into Data lineage and
which data is used even at scale and
then the other side which is as it's
produced you know how do you Watermark
it or or identify it but as you you all
know with like certificate authorities
and
websites it's like the least interesting
thing about the the the internet and I
worry that you know I think what we need
is societal and legal Norms that go with
that the technical implementation is not
going to be the either the answer or um
the
impediment and I think we're going to
need new Norms of when you modify
someone else else's not not even the
technical platform but you modify
someone else's material how is that
going to work how will licensing work so
I think all of that back to the question
of Regulation has to be a whole of
society question these I think we get in
trouble when you we as Engineers or we
as Society think there's a there's one
answer to these things and we've just
not found the mathematical equation
these are actually ongoing processes
that need feedback loops and and healthy
legitim
outcomes that people respect because
they'll
evolve have a question over
here so I kind of want to return back to
the idea of like um regulation under
industry verticals um so something that
I'm really interested in is that like it
seems really easy for all these
companies to talk about like these big
lofty ideas of like we need to be
regulated but when it comes down to the
actual language of like what these
regulations are um it becomes really
tricky and like the specific instance
that I'm thinking of is like when Sam
Altman um testified in front of Congress
and then um like saying that we need
more regulation but then a couple days
later the EU came out with a package and
open AI just completely rejected it um
so do you have any like ideas in mind to
like how to resolve this kind of issue
that we
see yeah and I again back to my banking
history
I think we need to get to a place where
there's a healthy and informed ongoing
refinement of the approach and so to
your point I think there's you know this
is new and people are posturing a bit in
all kinds of ways but the but what we
want is industry government this public
sector in whatever form iterating
towards something that works I don't I
guess my point is I don't think there's
a a single group within that who knows
enough to to write the perfect
regulation even if it existed and so
what we need is a healthy way to your
point we need a healthy way to have the
dialogue not to sort of reject things
out of hand but to refine them as we go
um because look I just said we talk
about I don't know what it'll look like
in a couple years talking about a large
a Frontier Model will that be like
that's a concept but is it well defined
enough to be basis of a regulation it's
a good question and so I think we need
to use that we need a vocabulary it's
partly why I go back to the domain
specific because again when we operate
it in these really high level
abstractions I'm not sure that it's even
implementable in some
cases let alone you know to people's
reactions to it whereas you can look at
outcomes in a domain even if the tech
change is under the under the
hood all right I think we have time for
maybe one
more and if there none I have one you
knew it was coming um great here do you
have yes
thank oh we need a mic for you I guess I
can hear you but yep I enjoyed your
analogy with cartography the definition
of a
country um
and it made me think of digital and and
um data sovereignity yeah um is it
correct to uh think that it's not too
late to Define so a Sovereign Nation
with respect to data and
digital uh and if so what criteria would
you can you think of what major high
level criteria would you focus on
you know back to the crypto discussion
we'll come back to my education here but
the
um we have built just as as one example
of of a an attempt on this what we call
Sovereign Cloud offering where instead
of it being you know we do you you can
do it in various
locations but we use crypto to define
the scope and so the cryptography
defines the
sovereignty completely really it's
in it's it's geographically meaningless
really but it gives the basis for a
discussion of this the scope of the data
I think you still have questions though
of what data is any data about me
because I'm an
American American data you know I think
there's lots of use cases but at least
if if somebody can say this is what we
want to consider the data of that
country I think cryptographic work
provides one possibility for how to
answer that the problem is the back the
practicalities no data lives on its own
I mean very little it needs to interact
with other data and so if you're using
crypto to do it you need some key
exchange or some means of combining data
and all of a sudden you make people
manage keys and people stink at
that so yes there's some offerings and I
think crypto provides it I don't think
that's the long-term answer though I
think we've got to come up with more
durable conceptual models of what the
the country its people its companies its
technical
infrastructure but I think that's work
I'd love to be doing I mean I honestly
think that's a question that the
university should should begin to have a
thesis about not necessarily
Google so last
question I Michael has one yeah we gotta
give Michael the mic yes yes okay well
turn it
on it's on okay it's on great so so I
just wanted to say that
um uh it's very easy for for
technologist to think about we have to
reach out into these other areas and
incorporate law and Medicine uh uh and
and political science into our thinking
and into our Technologies but I think
you made a good point
that that that it's the it's the players
in those fields that are going to be
determining our future and the and my
question is is can you give any advice
to
universities about how how we
can best get the te the the
technological foundations out to the
people that are going to be making these
decisions in other words um what you we
be doing to to to to to help our our our
related colleagues uh uh better
understand the technology and where it's
going and how it's going to affect them
it's a great question and I think the
tension is I mean I I think the best way
and we come back to it I we'll keep
doing this is
concrete questions that we can work on
together because I think you learn then
not just the the theory of it but you
the practice and I think that's what is
required to really learn and to to
develop that abstraction and language
that we can then use for the next
instance in the next instance so I think
concrete work where we answer questions
like what's a country on the internet
and then we force each other to learn
well what what do you mean uh a data
center like at some level people don't
really understand what that or or or how
um caching works right so the the and I
think you get into these sort of
Concepts concrete things the one thing I
would say and this is one thing I love
about Yale I do worry sometimes if the
over enthusiasm for data so one way this
all happens is everybody gets excited
about data right all these fields are
now quantitative in ways that it seem
ridiculous to me somewhat but um
um so I think that the key is not to to
be not to not to think of data as data
is a way to communicate it is not the
ideas in of itself so I think one of the
things university has to continue to
offer is to remind us that these ideas
are longer standing and these Concepts
go back much further the data is a way
to have a conversation is not the it
does not solve the conflict it does not
solve the partisanship in and of itself
so that's my I guess my one back and
forth on the advice is yeah let's work
on things sometimes that means people
get data and they work together I worry
that sometimes that you know stops
people from digging in at the real roots
of these problems
you well I want to thank Royal again for
joining us and uh enlightening us um
thank
you one of the one of the things I I
loved about his talk and about this
conversation is it kind of reaffirms I
think a belief that we share here that
there's work going on in the world and
technology companies and lots of
different places that is should be in
deep conversation with what we're doing
here in Academia the research we're
doing the teaching we're doing that
Walling ourselves off from these
advances uh does does us and Society no
good um so I'm thrilled that there seems
to be mutual enthusiasm for continuing
this conversation and I want to thank
you all for joining us here today uh so
more next semester thanks again thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you